je m'appelle Sylvain dramey je suis
professeur de sciences sociales et tous
les dimanches sur twitch je lis avec
vous un article de science sociale pour
le vulgariser pour que vous puissiez
vous initier ou réactualiser vos
connaissances par rapport aux recherches
les plus récentes de sciences sociales
aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser à un
article qui s'appelle à l'école des
chefs et qui va nous permettre de nous
immerger littéralement dans un lycée
professionnel français qui forme des
jeunes aux métiers de la gastronomie et
de la restauration non on va passer à
cet article où on va refaire du Pierre
Bourdieu parce que c'est vraiment un
article qui s'inscrit dans les travaux
de Pierre Bourdieu avec tout le
l'arsenal conceptuel de Pierre Bourdieu
si c'est plus trop clair pour vous on
reviendra là dessus et je repréciserai
ça de toute façon article de Adrien
pegourdi et le dit tout de suite que le
métier de la cuisine et du service
connaissent depuis plusieurs années
commence un processus de revalorisation
donc ça devient vraiment quelque chose
de très légitime tout ce qui est lié à
la gastronomie évidemment on peut penser
aux émissions culinaires le statut des
grands chefs évidemment le les
événements comme le guide Michelin enfin
la sortie du guide Michelin des choses
comme ça le fait aussi que la cuisine ou
la gastronomie française soit reconnue
comme Patrimoine culturel et immatériel
de l'Unesco tout ça fait que tu as
vraiment une revalorisation du monde en
tout cas de la restauration voire de
l'hôtellerie processus de revalorisation
cette revalorisation et cependant portée
par des dynamiques inégalitaires ça y
est on commence elle ne profite qu'à une
minorité de travailleurs du secteur
parvenant à cumuler rétribution
symbolique quand tu travailles dans un
grand palace il y a une rétribution
symbolique qui est le fait de travailler
dans ce grand palace certainement dans
dans le monde la restauration je sais
pas si c'est transposable dans d'autres
champs
vous travaillez par exemple pour une
grande entreprise ou une grande banque
est-ce que c'est encore aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a encore une rétribution
symbolique je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas dans le monde de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration ça marche encore et
matériel du fait des spécificités de
leurs clientèle cette minorité parce que
tout le monde ne va pas travailler dans
un palace au service des riches fait
partie de l'ensemble des professions
intervenants près des classes dominantes
dont les effectifs ont augmenté donc
nous rappelle que les classes dominantes
sont en augmentation
et les tâches se sont spécialisées pour
répondre au mieux à la demande de
service personnalisés d'une élite aux
revenus accrue moi j'aurais envie de
dire les caprices mais il y aura un
jugement de valeur dans le rapport de
subordination entre clients et
travailleurs s'opèrent un transfert de
capitaux autant économique induit par la
transaction marchande et les
gratifications exceptionnelles que
symboliques le prestige social de la
clientèle rejaillit sur ceux qui la
servent permettant au plus doté d'entre
eux de proposer une image valorisée de
leur activité à la frontière de l'art et
de l'artisanat néanmoins la grande part
de la main d'oeuvre des restaurants et
des hôtels restant en marge de satellite
gastronomique et subit des conditions de
travail et d'emploi peu avantageuses
alors d'autant plus que dans
l'univers professionnel
lambda de la restauration c'est très dur
c'est un travail qui est physiquement
éprouvant station debout port de charge
lourde déplacement nombreux activités
intenses lors du coup de feu du service
stress chaleur des cuisines des horaires
fractionnés et atypiques travail le
week-end les jours fériés en soirée
c'est difficile conscient de travail
sont couplés à des conditions d'emploi
dégradées ici on nous donne quelques
données chiffrées par exemple en 2019 le
salaire médian des cuisiniers à temps
complet était de 1500 euros par mois et
celui des employés et des agents de
maîtrise donc c'est-à-dire les serveurs
étaient de 1400 euros par mois
ce qui est plus peut-être qu'un SMIC
mais avec des conditions de travail qui
sont quand même très contraignantes par
rapport à quelqu'un qui travaillerait
dans les heures de bureau la part des
contrats précaires CDD et intérim
importantes aussi où tu as difficilement
un contrat à durée indéterminé tu as
difficilement aussi peut-être un temps
plein tout ça s'ajoute à la difficulté
et la pénibilité du travail qui n'est
certainement pas
comment dire une exception ça c'est
plutôt la norme et travailler dans les
palaces c'est plutôt l'exception et on
nous rappelle aussi qu'entre février
2018 et février 2020 ont eu aussi le
covid à ce moment là près d'un tiers des
salariés qui chaque année l'hôtellerie
restauration
je trouve que les chiffres
sont pas forcément parlants quoi du coup
et la restauration est au quatrième rang
des emplois saisonniers non pourvu avec
près de 55 000 offres
et l'Union des métiers des industries de
l'hôtellerie nous dit que on a l'automne
2021 il y avait plus de 100000 emplois
vacants dans ce que nous en Belgique on
appelle le Reck mais alors les raisons
de la pénurie de main d'oeuvre dans un
contexte de revalorisation de l'activité
culinaire
ça c'est l'objet cet article se penche
sur la manière dont sont formés les
futurs professionnels et de montrer que
finalement le lycée professionnel si ce
n'est pas une cause unique évidemment en
tout cas participe de cette pénurie de
main d'oeuvre voir pourquoi
le lycée hôtelier étudié est situé dans
une ville moyenne dispense une formation
classique en hôtellerie restauration
préparant les petites mains du secteur à
travers l'étude de ce lycée plus
spécifiquement d'une classe de
baccalauréat professionnel service et
restauration nous verrons comment la
désinfection des jeunes diplômés ne
s'explique pas seulement par les
conditions de travail dégradé et
l'emploi qui domine dans le restauration
mais aussi par la nature même de leur
formation donc c'est ça on est toujours
sur quelque chose de multi
multifactoriel et ça c'est un des
facteurs qu'on va étudier dans cet
article
alors on va pas non plus il faut pas non
plus attendre de trop de l'article moi
j'étais un peu déçu quand même de la
profondeur mais je voudrais pas vous
influencer sur votre évaluation finale
de l'article ce travail souligne combien
le lycée hôtelier détourne une partie
des élèves de l'entrée dans le monde
professionnel et suscite des aspirations
peu ajuster aux réalités du marché du
travail favorisant les sorties précoces
du métier l'institution et ses élèves
qui peut le plus peut le moins c'est
avec ces mots que le proviseur du lycée
hôtelier résume la formation dans son
établissement cette formule montre bien
l'influence du modèle de l'hélie
gastronomique donc on va former les
élèves à l'élite gastronomique avec des
règles avec des recettes complexes avec
des ingrédients nobles
parce qu'on se dit voilà s'ils sont
capables d'avoir des de faire de
respecter ce qui se fait au top niveau à
ce moment là ils pourront faire tous les
métiers dans la restauration et
l'hôtellerie mais finalement tu vois
déjà où est le problème
tu crées des attentes des mesurées et
puis la réalité du monde professionnel
est bien différente dans cette
institution il ne s'agit pas de former
uniquement des futurs professionnels du
luxe mais de transmettre une excellence
professionnelle en partant du principe
que cette formation permettrait ensuite
de travailler dans tous les domaines de
la restauration et tous les types
d'établissements y compris les mois
prestigieux d'entre eux toutefois ces
apprentissages décodent du luxe et
menées par des enseignants éloignés de
cet univers c'est ce que j'expliquais
soit parce qu'ils n'y ont jamais
travaillé soit parce qu'ils l'ont quitté
il y a plusieurs années
c'est donc une vision idéalisée et
suranné dépasser du service des classes
dominantes qui est transmise par la
formation
c'est quand même dingue quand tu penses
qu'il y ait des formations comme
celle-là qui soit au service en fait des
classes dominantes quoi tu vas former du
personnel pour servir la classe mais là
c'est une parenthèse
en outre les apprentissages qui passent
par l'enseignement de technique le
remodelage des corps et l'incultation
d'un amour entre guillemets du métier
s'opèrent auprès des élèves éloignés du
monde de la restauration et donc là il y
a un gap il y a une sorte alors le mot
n'est pas utilisé mais moi je trouvais
que le texte transpirer un petit peu ce
concept d'acculturation quand finalement
tu dois effacer une culture initiale
dans laquelle tu as tu es né tu as vécu
pour en acquérir une autre et parfois le
gap est très important et c'est ce qu'on
nous précise ici on constate une predo
prépondérance des origines populaires
trois quarts des élèves sont d'origine
populaire mais comme dans toutes les
filières professionnelles là il y a un
tri qui est fait avec les établissements
généraux qui vont être ou les classes
moyennes plus et les classes dominantes
vont être sûr représentées et puis dans
les filières qualifiantes comme on le
dira en Belgique tu auras plus de
classes populaires bien sûr c'est la
c'est en Belgique mais c'est pour vous
montrer que l'école
est encore une grande entreprise de
classement et de moi j'appelle ça une
gare de triage en fait
alors justement donc trois quarts des
élèves dans ce lycée professionnel
viennent des milieux populaires une
absence d'enfants des classes
supérieures bon on travaille à l'échelle
d'une classe de 23 élèves donc c'est pas
très représentatif mais il y a quand
même 0 enfant de classe supérieure et
tout ce y compris ceux issus des classes
moyennes ont un lien avec le pôle privé
de l'espace social alors là c'est très
intéressant il faut se remémorer ce que
dit Bourdieu je sais pas si vous en
souvenez mais je vous projetez
l'espace social selon Bourdieu et on va
revenir un peu là dessus
il y a des lectures qu'on a déjà faites
je sais pas si vous étiez là quand on a
lu le rapport des classes populaires à
l'écologie on avait beaucoup parlé
justement de cet emplacement de l'espace
social où on est dans les classe moyenne
ou dans les classes populaires mais pas
les classes populaires qui sont dans la
précarité classe populaire voilà
difficile de terminer le mois mais
stabiliser donc on sait que on a sans
doute le logement ou le crédit pour le
logement est en cours et donc c'est
vraiment cet espace là qui est
intéressant dans cet article dans cet
article si
voilà voilà ce qu'est l'espace social
pour Bourdieu
alors moi je généralement je ne je ne
travaille pas avec cette
avec cette représentation là auprès des
élèves parce qu'après ça devient un peu
trop déterministe parce que pour
Bourdieu en fait tout est en déplacement
constant et en fait ce sont des
positions relatives qui pourraient
changer si les policiers autres changent
donc en fait là c'est une vision fixiste
de l'espace social qui ne correspond pas
à ce que propose Bourdieu mais voilà ici
comme on en parle je vais quand même le
montrer donc cet espace social est
structuré
selon la détention de différents
capitaux encore une fois c'est une
vision un peu réductrice parce que pour
Bourdieu il y a plusieurs capitaux il y
a pas que deux capitaux or ici vous
voyez que on est surtout sur du capital
culturel du capital économique donc si
tu es à gauche
quand on regarde le
tableau tu as plus de capital
culturelles si tu es à droite tu as plus
de capital économique donc il y a une
structure du capital qui joue comme ça
et puis si tu es tout en haut tu as plus
de capital
dans toutes les espèces confondues voilà
ce qui est mis sur le tableau parce
qu'on va appeler le volume de capital en
bas tu as très peu de capital alors
comme tu as très peu de capital bah il
est très peu différencié et donc c'est
pour ça que sur le bas voyez c'est un
peu en forme d'entonnoir
parce que tu peux pas avoir beaucoup de
capital culturelles étant donné que de
toute façon de manière totale tu n'as
pas beaucoup de capital
sauf que bon pour Bourdieu il y a aussi
du capital social qui intervient qu'on a
représente pas ici et puis il y a une
sorte de synthèse qui est faite avec du
capital symbolique mais qui n'est pas
vraiment une synthèse et donc cette
vision-ci est très réductrice
et en fait sur
l'article on nous dit que les 23 élèves
proviennent quand ils sont des classes
moyennes surtout de la partie droite
donc vous voyez où il y a petit
commerçants artisans alors après vous
voyez en écriture normale pétant que
Pernot pêche parce que pour Bourdieu il
y a une association qui est faite entre
ta position sociale et tes pratiques
culturelles
mais encore une fois c'est une vision
réductrice parce que ça pourrait changer
la pétanque instant pour être comment
dire réinvesti par les classes
dominantes une sorte de gentrification
des pratiques qui pourraient se faire et
donc ça le schéma ici ne serait plus
juste et souvent il y a des personnes
qui vont dire oui mais Bourdieu tout ça
ça n'est plus correct ça n'est plus à
jour Bourdieu c'est dépassé oui mais ça
c'est la vision à l'époque de Bourdieu
Bourdieu n'a pas dit que c'était comme
ça
pour toujours
donc ça c'est l'espace social et voyons
on va vraiment être sur en fait la case
en bas à droite on va se trouver dans
cet espace là
donc on est en fait sur aussi sur sur
une pratique sociale dans les lycées
professionnels qui est assez situé
socialement leurs parents une situation
professionnelle relativement stable et
occupe des emplois d'ouvriers et
d'employer du secteur privé
d'agriculture d'agriculteurs pardon
d'artisans de profession du maintien de
l'ordre des policiers des militaires des
vigiles et de techniciens donc on est
vraiment sur cet espace qu'on a ciblé de
l'espace social seul trois élèves ont
des liens familiaux avec le secteur de
l'hôtellerie restauration
3 sur 23
ouais 3 sur 23
à travers la profession de la mer
cuisinière et propriétaire d'un
restaurant de croisine de cuisine
traditionnelle pour l'un d'un oncle
serveur salarié dans un établissement de
chaîne pour l'autre et d'un cousin
serveur salarié dans un bar-restaurant
pour le dernier les élèves sont
également homogènes quant à leur
trajectoire scolaire en entretien tous
reconnaissent avoir connu des
difficultés scolaires au collège
caractérisées par un redoublement et ou
de faible de résultats en classe de 3e
et donc on retrouve exactement ce qu'on
disait en Belgique où tu as un
déclassement qui est fait globalement
tous les élèves essaient des filières
générales d'abord et puis après tu vas
en filière professionnelle je dis bien
généralement après il y a toujours des
cas particuliers il y a des poissons
volants qui existent mais c'est pas
l'essentiel de l'espèce et puis ils
veulent pas vraiment
mais voilà quoi bien sûr tu as des
exceptions des gens qui ont une vocation
et qui vont tu vas prendre cet exemple
là pour contredire tout toutes les
généralités qui se font mais comme je le
dis souvent on fait pas de loi avec des
cas particuliers et donc ici tu vois
bien qu'on retrouve ce système de
déclassement qui est pas l'objet de
l'article
d'acceptation des verdicts scolaires
négatifs au sein des classes populaires
donc ce qui nous disent ici c'est qu'il
y a une intériorisation des verdicts
scolaires je suis pas fait pour l'école
alors que c'est l'école qui n'a pas été
faite pour eux mais il y a un
renversement qui est fait chez les
classes populaires on se dit ben
finalement l'école c'est pas fait pour
nous je dis nous parce que les parents
aussi ont sans doute eu peut-être eu des
difficultés scolaires et donc finalement
ben voilà on accepte sa trajectoire
c'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
avec TVA finalement il y a une sorte de
trajet tragédie du social qui moi
comment dire
me
m'étonne tout le temps quoi me révolte
ou m'étonnes mais je ne me lasse pas de
m'étonner de ça quelque part je sais pas
si c'est clair quand je dis je ne me
lasse pas de m'étonner de ça mais voilà
c'est je trouve ça
incroyable que ça soit encore si peu
conscientisé dans la société alors que
ça a été tellement Dié redis quoi et qui
a tellement de de faits qui qui
s'ajoutent les uns aux autres même si
dans les sciences sociales évidemment on
ne fait pas des sciences exactes c'est
pas la même chose mais il y a quand même
des faits qui sont là qui ont été
construits de manière rigoureuse et qui
s'accumule les uns après les autres
alors ici c'est toujours des moments que
j'aime quand on laisse parler les
individus les gens c'est toujours
chouette d'avoir vraiment les mots
qu'ils ont donné ici on est sur Pauline
fille d'agriculteurs inscrite en cuisine
bain au début je savais pas trop quoi
faire quand en troisième on m'a dit
qu'il fallait faire un choix je me suis
porté vers la cuisine j'ai fait un stage
en entreprise pendant quatre jours et ça
m'a beaucoup plu en fait rien ne me
plaisait le général j'avais pas envie du
coup je me suis dit pourquoi pas aller
tester en entreprise dans un restaurant
pour voir comme je cuisine n'est pas mal
à la maison pour voir si ça me plaisait
autant au restaurant et du coup c'est
pour ça que je suis là donc tu vois que
tu es pas non plus sur un choix ultra
positif à la base mais là c'est encore
un choix qui est relativement positif
dans l'autre moitié des élèves on va
plutôt même avoir un choix par défaut
qu'il a pas du tout positif
donc ici Mathieu nous dit je voulais
travailler dans tout ce qui était nature
animaux garde forestier et ben le blanc
cuisine c'était vraiment autre chose
qu'ici quoi et du coup je suis arrivé là
en fait je suis venu par hasard sur un
coup de tête quand j'ai redoublé ma
troisième j'ai déjà demandé une année en
lycée agricole et j'étais carrelé parlé
pardon parce que j'avais pas assez de
moyenne donc il voulait faire garde
forestier forestier
travailler dans l'agriculture et ici
surtout en cuisine et du coup je me suis
dit je vais aller en cuisine parce que
là c'est plus facile on m'avait dit que
c'était beaucoup plus facile de rentrer
du coup je suis vraiment venu comme ça
par hasard il y avait aucune chose avant
qui m'avait vraiment donné envie de
venir ici bonjour le choix positif à
l'image d'autres types d'institutions
qui entendent transformer leurs membres
le lycée hôtelier se caractérise par une
coupure avec le monde extérieur donc là
c'est intéressant on nous dit vraiment
qu'il y a un travail pour désoci
réaliser quelque part pour acculturer
les élèves et donc on nous dit que se
lisait ce lycée là et que c'est le cas
de beaucoup de lycées professionnels est
à l'extérieur de la ville loin de la vie
sociale mais aussi loin de lieux de
décision finalement de là où les choses
se passent il passe leur temps libre du
coup en petit groupe dans ou à proximité
de l'établissement parce qu'il y a rien
d'autre à faire aux alentours coupez
d'une partie des interactions avec le
monde extérieur si la situation est
moins due à une stratégie d'institution
cause inégalités socio-spatiale qui
repousse en périphérie les populations
les plus populaires et en l'occurrence
ici leur lieu d'apprentissage
l'isolement caractérise bien la
scolarité des élèves du lycée hôtelier
donc il y a des choses j'aime bien
l'idée aussi que les choses rentrent en
résonance comme cette ce phénomène
physique dans lequel les atomes d'une
matière vont vibrer en même temps et où
tu vois ces ponts qui se déforment
littéralement et donc ici en fait c'est
pas du tout volontaire de la part du
lycée de hôtelier ou de
du fait de l'éducation nationale de
vouloir aller à l'extérieur de la ville
mais il se trouve que ça va renforcer
cet effet d'isolement quoi donc c'est
vraiment des choses qui un faisceau de
circonstances qui renforce un phénomène
cours généraux cours professionnel repas
du midi et mise en situation
professionnelle à travers le restaurant
et l'hôtel d'applications sont assurés
au service du lycée et organisé par
l'administration selon l'emploi du temps
ritualisé tout ça pour te dire que voilà
il y a vraiment un formatage qui est mis
en place
loin d'être un espace uniforme le lycée
hôtelier est donc un lieu de subtiles
différenciation entre formation que les
vêtements servent à illustrer parce que
tu as les boucher qui vont être habillés
d'une certaine manière les serveurs
d'une autre manière il y a une photo qui
est proposée je vous la montrerai et on
nous parle d'une violence retenue de la
part de l'école
l'objectif de transformation des élèves
s'inscrit ainsi dans une volonté
revendiquée de ne pas selon l'équipe
pédagogique dégoûté les élèves plusieurs
raisons justifient ce recours à une
violence retenue parce que tu dois faire
une violence pour formater les élèves
mais en même temps tu peux pas
être trop violent sinon il s'en vont
jusqu'ici ils sont sur base plus ou
moins volontaires même s'il y a des
choix par défaut comme on l'a vu
le secteur de l'hôtellerie restauration
en effet était l'objet au milieu des
années 2010 d'une campagne médiatique de
dénonciation des violences physiques
morales sexistes à l'oeuvre dans ce
monde professionnel et donc du coup tu
as un climat qui est plutôt à être plus
soft dans les rapports sociaux qui fait
que les profs sont dans la retenue la
seconde raison de la retenue de la
violence réside dans l'absence de
sélection des élèves l'institution n'est
donc pas en mesure de choisir des élèves
possédant des dispositions favorables au
travail de conversion
donc il y a un manque de docilité mais
pas forcément sur un fond volontaire du
matériau que tu veux modeler le matériau
étant les élèves
et ici on a Marc
enseignante cuisine qui nous dit les
exigences d'un établissement scolaire ne
sont plus les mêmes avant le prof disait
quelque chose personne ne bronchait
aujourd'hui c'est plus comme cela si on
veut mettre une sanction on ne peut plus
non plus on a quand même des barrières
les chefs d'établissement ont la
pression voire même un peu peur de pour
des poursuites on laisse un peu faire
les choses le lycée hôtelier se retrouve
ainsi dans une situation complexe un peu
dans une double bride dans une double
contrainte il doit entreprendre un
travail de conversion des élèves à un
monde social étranger sans pouvoir
déployer les méthodes d'une institution
totale une institution totale comme par
exemple
un hôpital psychiatrique où tu as
totalement prises ou une prison tu as
totalement prise sur les individus
reste alors le recours à une violence
retenue qui ne produit les effets
escomptés que dans quelques cas où la
logique institutionnelle entre en
résonance on utilise ce mot de résonance
avec certains acquis de la socialisation
familiale donc il y avait trois élèves
sur les 23 il y avait de la famille dans
le milieu de la restauration
sans doute qu'auprès de ses élèves là il
y aura une meilleure réception de
l'entreprise de
de formatage à l'instar des autres
formations professionnelles la formation
en hôtellerie restauration s'emploie en
premier lieu à transmettre des
techniques professionnelles et un
vocabulaire spécifique l'objectif
consiste à ce que ces techniques et ce
vocabulaire deviennent naturelle pour
les élèves entre guillemets c'est à dire
suffisamment incorporé pour que leur
exécution relève d'un sens pratique on
trouve vraiment les mots de Bourdieu ici
il s'agit de développer
incorporer sans pratique c'est des mots
de la sociologie de Bourdieu il s'agit
de développer une maîtrise du corps dans
l'action qui permet de produire
instantanément et quasi mécaniquement
une réponse donc c'est vraiment un
travail de conditionnement adapté à une
situation de travail pour cela le lycée
multiplie les exercices répétitifs une
sorte de drill et imposée ayant pour but
de façonner et d'éduquer les corps aux
exigences du métier
nous avons Claude ancien de cuisine qui
témoigne au niveau de l'apprentissage
c'est graduel en première année on part
sur des objectifs de préparation des
bases en fait ça va être des choses
simples comme préparer laver sécher
hacher du persil ça on va le voir une
fois deux fois faudra peut-être le voir
trois fois car certains vont encore
laisser des queues de persil au milieu
après on va essayer de passer toutes les
techniques de cuisson
de façon à ce qu'il voit la palette des
techniques de cuisson en cuisine
française tout un tas de choses qui vont
faire une base de connaissances au
départ et puis ensuite en deuxième année
on va s'appuyer sur cette base de
connaissances pour aller plus loin
aujourd'hui on apprend plus tous les
classiques de la cuisine française ce
qui ne veut pas dire qu'on en fait pas
ça c'était quand j'ai appris la cuisine
il y a 40 ans aujourd'hui on leur
apprend des techniques qui vont être
transférables par exemple je vais faire
un steak tartare je vais utiliser
exactement la même technique que quand
je hache du persil aujourd'hui on leur
apprend des techniques et avec ces
techniques on va fabriquer des plats
sauf que c'est contre-productif et même
si pédagogiquement c'est vraiment
pertinent de partir des briques
fondamentales avec lesquels tu vas
construire après un édifice beaucoup
plus complexe et bien ça va être
contre-productif et tu as ta façon de
faire des effets en plus de
l'apprentissage technique c'est
également un important vocabulaire
spécifique que doivent s'approprier les
élèves les cuisiniers ont à retenir
l'ensemble des en termes désignant les
ustensiles et les techniques culinaires
qui leur serviront à exécuter avec
précision les recettes demandées les
serveurs doivent maîtriser tout le
vocabulaire associé au fromage et aux
alcools produits dont ils ont la charge
dans les restaurants dans ce cadre une
attention spécifique et portée sur le
lexique de l'œnologie lors de la
formation les élèves apprennent les
cépages et les régions viticoles
françaises ils sont initiés au
subtilités permettant de qualifier les
différents vins les gammes de famili
aromatiques les différentes courbes de
couleurs de robe les deux la degré le
degré d'intensité d'équilibre
ce vocabulaire œnologique développé
précis et abscons nécessite un travail
long et soutenu pour être réutilisé à
bon escient ouais c'est un travail que
enfin c'est un vocabulaire que tu
intériorises peu à peu quand tu
t'intéresses au monde de nos logis au
vin mais ici voilà au pas de charge aux
élèves tu peux bien imaginer le résultat
que ça donne
il faudra le remobiliser face aux
clients lors de l'interaction marchande
avec le naturel attendu c'est-à-dire
l'attitude permettant de fait miser la
relation marchande en donnant
l'impression aux clients qu'il
bénéficient d'une recommandation
personnalisée pour les apprentis
serveurs issus des classes moyennes et
populaires du secteur privé la
mobilisation de ce vocabulaire se révèle
complexe à mettre en œuvre pour eux il
ne s'agit pas seulement d'apprendre un
vocabulaire mais d'acquérir les codes
sociaux linguistiques non transmis par
leur socialisation familiale qui
permettent de l'utiliser avec justesse
dans la relation commerciale
l'observation des cours souligne la
difficulté de cet apprentissage malgré
les mises en situation professionnelle
sous la forme de jeu de rôle qui sont
utilisés par les professeurs
voilà ça c'est le genre de fiches que tu
utilises
alors les élèves voilà doivent
dire si le vin est pâle clair paille
doré cuivré en vrai grena violacé
oui tu vois tu vas vite comprendre
trouble voilé malgré la répétit la
répétition des gestes et la diversité
des lieux et des techniques
d'apprentissage l'acquisition des
techniques reste entravées par une
logique des compétences trop abstraite
pour des élèves à distance de la culture
scolaire de même l'apprentissage du
vocabulaire œnologique au culte
l'important investissement réclamé aux
élèves qui doivent à la fois acquérir un
capital culturel spécifique non transmis
par la socialisation familiale et
apprendre à le mobiliser dans des
interactions avec une clientèle
bourgeoise en fait ce qu'on demande
c'est un travail assez colossal face à
l'ampleur de la tâche le découragement
et le renoncement pointe chez les élèves
particulièrement pour les serveurs
directement exposés par la relation de
service alors distance au capital
culturel légitime alors que les
cuisiniers sont protégés par leur
travail à distance des clients donc
voilà tu rajoutes une difficulté pour
les serveurs
qui sont en plus des fonctions qui sont
moins payées après sur le marché du
travail
en plus de l'incorporation de nouvelles
techniques et d'un nouveau vocabulaire
la conversion implique une opération de
remodelage corporel les élèves
issus des classes moyennes et populaires
sont engagés dans un travail de
domestication du corps afin de le rendre
conforme aux exigences du service auprès
des classes supérieures c'est terrible
il y a aussi toute une volonté de
transformer les goûts des élèves
déjà par rapport au travail mais aussi
des goûts culinaires donc ça c'est très
compliqué à mettre en œuvre
et ici ça rejoint un petit peu ce que tu
disais puisque les jeunes cuisiniers
vont être appelés à redécouvrir des
viandes des poissons des légumes avec
plus de subtilité que ce qu'il pouvait
connaître dans leur milieu familial
Claude enseignant de cuisine d'un bon
dressage révèle le décalage entre les
exigences du lycée et les productions
actuelles de l'éligastronomique on a des
règles de dressage lorsqu'on a plusieurs
couleurs il faut intervertir les
couleurs si on a un logo sur le bord de
l'assiette le principal du plat doit
être le plus près possible du logo et
puis l'accompagnement sera un peu plus
loin si on a quelque chose avec un os
l'os sera vers l'intérieur du plat
jamais vers l'extérieur on ne mettra
jamais rien sur le Tour de l'assiette le
tour de l'assiette est réservé aux
clients et aux serveurs après on peut
laisser libre cours à une certaine
interprétation du volume des couleurs
dans l'assiette on doit réfléchir à ça
et c'est ce qu'on va faire carré rond ou
déstructuré en sachant que c'est plus
forcément les règles dans le milieu
gastronomique ou en fait on est sur une
défformalisation dans le milieu
gastronomique maintenant c'est beaucoup
plus beaucoup moins gainé et même dans
les rapports interpersonnels il y a un
rapport qui est beaucoup plus informel
que par le passé et donc dans le lycée
professionnel on va continuer à faire de
l'ultra formalisme si je puis dire je
sais pas si c'est exact mais c'est comme
ça que je le perçois alors que c'est
plus court donc on va même créer un
apprentissage ou en apprentissage de
choses qui ne sont plus actuellement et
en fait il va y avoir des thèmes
positifs en fait ce qu'ils attendent les
enseignants et c'est un implicite aussi
c'est des élèves qui sont
dévoués à 100% pour la cuisine aussi en
dehors de temps scolaire donc à la
maison il y est voilà un entraînement
qui soit fait qu'il développe par
eux-mêmes leur culture culinaire
on va attendre aussi une attitude de
quelqu'un qui est dévoué à 100% sur la
tâche avec des termes comme ah ça c'est
un bosseur une machine de guerre un
bastonner quoi de type Etchebest
finalement
et on attend que l'élève termine le
service épuisés en sueur donc on attend
plus finalement que les contenus
d'apprentissage
mais ça c'est valable aussi donc toutes
les filières qui est une sorte de don de
soi alors peut-être plus dans cette
filière là que dans d'autres filières
alors comme tu es sur des tâches qui
sont très complexes à l'intérieuriser
pour les élèves c'est ce qu'on a dit
pendant la majorité de l'article comme
on est aussi sur des conditions
professionnelles très difficiles d'un
milieu qui est très difficile qui est en
fait malgré sa valorisation sociale mais
dévaloriser économiquement en tout cas
pour la majorité des travailleurs tu
dois avoir un peu une carotte et la
carotte ça va être justement la
gastronomie le luxe les palaces
les professeurs vont faire miroiter ça
aux élèves en leur disant ben voilà il y
a du travail c'est dur c'est compliqué
tu vas en chier mais au final il y aura
quelque chose de très positif pour toi
sauf que on l'a vu il y a beaucoup
d'appelés peu d'élus surtout que
généralement le personnel n'est pas là
vont plutôt dans des écoles privées ou
des écoles qui vont former
spécifiquement
du personnel de palace avec une
sélection sociale qui est beaucoup plus
drastique avec des classes populaires
qui sont moins présentes et qu'au final
tous ces élèves des classes de lycée
professionnel vont se retrouver sur le
marché du travail avec peu de
possibilités d'aller dans des palaces
alors il y en aura d'ailleurs ici dans
le lycée ils expliquent que dans le hall
d'entrée il y a des photos de des élèves
qui ont le mieux réussi qui travaillent
dans ces dipalaces ou dans ces
restaurants gastronomiques mais voilà
c'est pour ça aussi que tu as une grosse
sortie du métier
plus tard parce qu'en fait tu crées des
attentes tu inculques des comportements
qui sont en total décalage avec le monde
professionnel et donc on est un petit
peu dans une impasse j'espère que cette
lecture vous a plu n'oubliez pas le
dimanche à 21h sur twitch nous lisons
chaque semaine un article de sciences
sociales et tu es évidemment le bienvenu
à très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
ou en stream
[Musique]